I want you to listen very closely to
this monologue this Schumer sham a shift
show it's over and I'm going to tell you
why it's over
I listen closely to every detail of the
president's defense including the
actions of quid and pro and quo Joe and
zero experience hunter and how Joe shook
down the country of Ukraine everyone
looked at what hunter and Joe did and
we're doing and said they don't do this
Hunter has zero experience in Ukraine no
experience in oil no experience in gas
no experience in energy hunter Biden got
a whopping eighty four thousand dollars
a month
did you know Pam Bondi told us the
average American family may of four
makes less than $54,000 in a year
everyone knew everyone knows now
everyone saw this at the time for what
this was then you have Joe Biden we just
passed a two-year anniversary Joe Biden
on tape admitting to the shakedown and
by the way at a minimum everyone sees
what this is we can identify it we have
identified several potential serious
violations of the law felony look at
this on your screen the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act 15 USC seven eight
quote it is illegal for a US person to
course oh you're not getting the billion
unless you have fire or influence
through bribery or extortion if you fire
him you get the billion a foreign nation
into taking action that might
financially benefit that person his
family hunter or business and that's not
all bribery 18 USC 201 C whoever
corruptly gives offers or promises
anything of value to a public official
to influence an official act is guilty
of bribery you're not getting the
billion let you fire the prosecutor
paying my zero experience on 83 grand a
month
millions and millions of dollars oh we
found another law it's called the
gratuities Act 18 USC 201 B giving
offering promising anything of value to
a public official in exchange for any
official act uh-oh and the Hobbs Act 18
USC 1951 a threat to a foreign official
in order to obtain an official benefit
affecting interstate foreign commerce
would constitute extortion now never
forget it is the President of the United
States his duty his sworn duty to
faithfully execute the laws of the land
tonight the country now needs to make a
transition this BS witch hunt is over it
has to be over the president will
rightly be acquitted and vindicated for
good reason and I'll explain go back to
the Trump Solinsky called that the
president released freely during the
call what was the president worried
about he was worried about Ukrainian
corruption he was concerned remember
szalinski was working with some of the
same bad actors in the previous
Ukrainian administration the poroshenko
administration and he was worried
Ukraine had interfered in the 2016
election separate and apart from Russian
interference that Devin unas warned us
all about in 2014 a Ukrainian court had
determined government officials
interfered in our election a January
2017 January 11 to be exact
investigative report from Politico
detailed Ukrainian interference we have
described it in detail and after by the
way three years never ending non-stop
Lying hysteria about for an election in
appearance it would have been a
dereliction of duty would it not for
president Trump to not rightly address
the issue do us a favor
my country's been through all of this
can we get to the bottom of it he never
mentioned date or a quid or a pro or a
call like Joe and let's not forget on
the very call in question
not a penny was ever
mentioned now there are weak Republicans
in this country so-called moderate
Democrats in the US Senate thinking
about giving validation to this Schumer
ship sham show with new witnesses and
new investigations well to all of you
that are thinking about that you are not
only ripping the country apart you are
spitting in the face of every
law-abiding American your constituents
because this president was looking out
for their money
and you are also simultaneously
trampling on and shredding the
Constitution of the United States
because of what a shameful political
stunt because you can't wait 280 days
knowing you're likely gonna well lose in
the next election well how stupid and
dangerous do you want to be here because
the total BS surrounding Bolton is just
the latest manufactured crisis now I've
known Joe I've known John Bolton floor I
think two decades thereabouts I have a
message for John Bolton tonight he used
to be a colleague here at the Fox News
Channel I remember when John was first
up for the job a national security
adviser I had heard through many sources
John was calling everyone that would
listen asking them to put in a good word
for him with President Trump he wanted
this job badly I spoke on an occasion to
John Bolton and I asked him why he
wanted the job and I also remember
asking him well you know Donald Trump's
foreign policies positions are very
different than your foreign policies
positions would you be willing to serve
his agenda not yours again I've known
him for two decades now I'm not today
recognizing the guy that I thought I
knew because John Bolton I say to you
tonight you have something to say John
come here you worked here this is your
old home come on the show and have your
say on this show we've invited you
repeatedly radio and TV over the past
number of weeks now nobody I think truly
knows what's in his book except for
whatever manuscript he might have sent
who ever seen it I have no idea of any
of these report
true but let's assume for a second that
they are true here's the bottom line Jim
Jordan has reminded us four facts never
change this case is over why because the
Trump Solinsky transcripts they show
zero linkage between US aid and any
investigation the one fact witness and
the house said when he asked the
president what do you want nothing
absolutely nothing no quid pro or quo
both Trump infers Alinsky they have
denied repeatedly that any aid was
conditional there was never any pressure
whatsoever szalinski even going so far
as what are you people talking about
what are you doing over there at the
time of the initial call Ukrainian
officials never knew that the US aid was
temporarily paused and don't forget and
this is critical
even if Donald Trump maybe said oh they
better do this or I'm not giving him any
a let's assume he might have even said
that doesn't matter does it because the
fourth fact that never changes that the
aid was released one case earlier with
zero strings attached and that means
they got the aid they never did anything
they never said they'd do anything they
never called for an investigation they
never said they'd call for an
investigation and they have said all of
that repeatedly and I add one fifth well
if you will fact that will never change
there were five SEP separate subsequent
high-level meetings in the meetings with
Solinsky all those audition witnesses
here saying opinion witnesses all said
the same thing
aid was never discussed linkage was
never brought up so you have here an
anonymous source telling what a liberal
hack from the liberal New York Times and
hates Donald Trump that john bolton in a
manuscript well is claiming the
president wanted ukraine to investigate
the Biden's and maybe election
interference okay let's assume that's
true and that's a big if considering its
the New York Times but let's say it's
true does it make any difference well I
would answer absolutely none
so ever now the DOJ and the chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney they totally refute
bolton's claims now you have conflicting
testimony at best Bolton's testimony
would be heavily disputed but again the
facts don't change even then it doesn't
matter one bit
president Trump is allowed to talk he's
allowed to vent he's allowed to exchange
ideas with his close advisers that is
not a crime it's kind of like well you
tell your friend I want to rob this
jewelry store I want to rob this grocery
store convenience store or oh I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna punch this guy in
the face I'm gonna rip somebody's face
off but you never do it you weren't
seriously plotting the act that would
not be a crime now would it we all think
about things thoughts flow through our
brains constantly these two few are
conservative and when you think about
things that's not a crime
in any way and in the White House it's
certainly not a crime to talk about
policy ideas or to vent
now if the president did what they said
it would still be so in significantly
meaningless that it would never rise to
the equation to the level of quid pro
quo Joe and zero experience hunter so if
we use senators you know if you're gonna
validate thought crimes to smear a duly
elected president just 280 days before
the election when the facts never change
well John Bolton could say over know the
president said there's gonna be linkage
but there never was we will be in big
trouble as a country if you legitimize
this John Bolton come on the show your
country wants to hear from you I'd like
to hear from you you have a story to
tell the country John stop playing games
this is not a game when it's the
presidency of the United States it's not
a game when you're pushing the
boundaries of executive privilege which
George Washington used and every
president pretty much in between and
since take a look the trial of the
leader of the free world and the duly
elected president of the United States
it is not a game of leaks and unsourced
manuscripts that's politics
unfortunately now to be specific
you cannot impeach a president on an
unsourced allegation but to have have a
removal of a duly elected president
based on a policy disagreement that is
not what the framers intended and if you
lower the bar that way Danger Danger
Danger
yep Jay's right what's happening here is
dangerous now a small group of
Republican senators well they're
thinking of caving to the Democratic
colleagues maybe they want to be liked
maybe they're putting their own election
results ahead of the Constitution what's
in the best interest of the country and
the principle of executive privilege and
the right of a president to get free and
fair and open advice from his top
advisers maybe they want the Democrats
to get all the witnesses they want maybe
they want the smear to go on and on and
on and because of the New York Times
saying in a manuscript that Bolton might
have said that the president's one
that's had linkage but linkage never
happened and let me say one other thing
I want to address Mitt Romney
I'd like to Mitt Romney Mitt Romney I
think would have been a great president
in 2012 he was the better person to be
President I thought I was friends with
Mitt Romney I don't recognize this guy
anymore another one he has been a huge
disappointment I thought he would have
been a better president than Obama
we all went all-in wanted him to win
like his family wife kids wonderful
people but this sanctimonious Trump
hatred is getting old especially as you
watch the president accomplishing
everything you said Mitt Romney you
wanted to have happen in the country
really mitt look at the four facts on
say five that never change ukranian said
they never felt pressure they never ever
did a single thing they never said
they'd do a thing and they got
all their money so do you really think
that you should take on the role of the
US House of Representatives the sole
constitutional role to impeach and now
you want to put on a whole other case
and take on their job all I see with all
due respect Mitt Romney is your personal
hatred for Donald Trump and it's clearly
clouding your judgment do you really
think Americans are too stupid to choose
their president
Mitt Romney senator we have an election
in 280 days why don't you go out and
campaign for quitter proloquo Joe I
haven't heard you talk about quid pro
quo Joe I haven't heard you talk about
zero experience hunter either I haven't
heard you ask for them to be called as
witnesses really you're not getting the
billion unless you fire the prosecutor
that's investigating my zero experience
son you don't want him as a witness and
do you not think that the president
knowing this is saying wow that seems
really bad admit I'll send over to your
office tomorrow all the applicable laws
in the case of quid pro quo Joe and zero
experience hunter and by the way the
media that's loving you now mitt they
were the same people that were out there
say you're a misogynist you are a racist
you cut some kids hair in grade school
they were the ones saying everything and
anything about you to destroy you do you
think they like you do you think they're
gonna like you never and this goes for
you other Republican senators you really
believe the very same Democrats that
accused that innocent man just as
Cavanaugh of being a serial gang rapists
and put the country through all of that
mess are you going to believe the same
congenital Liars that pushed the Russian
hoax conspiracy theories for over three
years never touch Hillary Clinton's
dirty Russian dossier never touched
premeditated fraud on the FISA abuse
spying on a presidential campaign a
transition team in a presidency you want
to trust those guys the hacks that have
been plotting impeachment since 2016 all
through 2017 1890
this Boulton hysteria manufactured
crisis to use a term is just the latest
things
sample and what is let's see the medium
mob which is state-run media for the
Democratic radical socialist party and
their phony feigned selective moral
outrage
it's the latest so-called bombshell it
really is a bombshell destroying this
administration this is it we got it's a
bombshell bombshell bombshell take a
look bombshell former National Security
Advisor John Bolton ready to turn on the
president as news leaks from his
explosive new book Bolton drops the
bombshell in an unpublished manuscript
for his forthcoming book an explosive
new account from former national
security adviser John Bolton John
Bolton's book which is as explosive as
expected bombshell report uh pending the
impeachment trial of President Ron
Bolton's bombshell the Bolton bombshell
that new book by John Bolton is called
the room where it happened and it could
be a bombshell oh and tonight by the way
we just learned that in fact we have oh
the ticket that in fact oh it was
Chuckie Schumer has where we learned
that Chuck Schumer gave a ticket to
tomorrow's impeachment hearing to let
poor Ness that's the guy indicted by the
Southern District of New York I kind of
think they're really serious people also
say campaign finance reform and also say
that he took a million dollars from
Russia and didn't want to report it